if you know one person they will know
someone here etc etc you know hey that's
what we do as recruiters have our job in
a sense is to networking or we're
talking to people all day we're talking
to clients all day we're talking to
candidates all day we find everyone
knows each other so I would say really
really latch onto your network and going
to events you know or like you said if
you know a candidate and you've placed
them what's the company that they've
came from or what colleagues do they
have if you are working with a leader in
the business you know if you're taking
them out for a drink you know meeting
them up for a meeting you're going to be
saying you know who do you know and just
talk about the market